forgetting lubricator
forgetting is a good thing hi there
Steve Kaufman and today I want to talk
about vocabulary
and the importance of forgetting
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the Bell to
get notified when there's a new video
and if you're on a podcast service
please leave a comment I really do
appreciate it so when I wrote I should
yeah when I wrote my book here's of
course the English version here's I'll
just happen to have the Chinese version
nearby
a personal guide to language learning
the linguist I called it
linguist means someone who you know
speaks many languages that's the
original meaning of the word linguist
whenever I say that I get attacked by
people who study Linguistics but if you
open up a dictionary that in fact is the
number one meaning of the word linguist
most English speakers are not familiar
with the word polylot anyway when I
wrote that book I said the most
important sort of measure of how well we
know a language is the number of words
we know vocabulary is key words and
phrases but phrases consist of words so
you have to have words and to be fluent
you actually need a lot of words because
the native speaker has a lot of words so
if you're exposing yourself to a native
speaker speakers in conversation or
watching a movie or listening to a
podcast all of which are tremendous ways
of improving in the language you need a
lot of words and while I sometimes hear
people say well I can be fluent with 500
words because 500 Words accounts for 60
of most content but in fact that's not
true because the low frequency words and
frequency declines very quickly as I've
said before their key to you know the
gist of what any content is about
the high frequency words are not a
problem they repeat often very quickly
get to know them but you need these
other words you need a high sort of
vocabulary level so how do we achieve
that I think one of the things that can
help us is if we accept the fact that
we're going to forget not only accept
the fact that we're going to forget but
realize that forgetting is a key part of
the strategy of learning and there are a
number of references and I did a bit of
Googling so you know I I Googled the
post Marcel pusti the French uh you know
novelist and he has this term lubricator
or the creative effect of forgetting and
sometimes those things that we don't
deliberately try to remember they kind
of stay there that was his intuition
now if you want to see a more scientific
a sort of explanation of that concept I
uh I recommend that you Google for
Robert Bjork uh b-j-o-r-k and the word
forgetting and you'll see a number of of
videos that he has done which explains
why forgetting is such an important part
of learning that in our memory we have
the ability to retrieve something but we
also have this issue of what we have in
storage okay and to some extent if we
try to train the ability to retrieve a
limited set of information words for
example we aren't building up that
storage larger storage of material that
we may not be able to retrieve right now
but it's their potentially available for
us to retrieve and he explains very
clearly that once we forget something
and we retrieve it again and maybe we
forget it again and we retrieve it again
we're expanding that sort of reserve of
things that we can uh retrieve we are
developing a large vocabulary and to do
well in languages we need a large
vocabulary even if our large passive
vocabulary
is not available to us to use or
gradually becomes available for us to
use it is enabling us to understand to
understand you know interesting
conversations or interesting sources of
of information in the language so I
think sometimes in schools we are
trained to not want to forget we're
trained you know the teacher teaches
something and we've now got to try to
remember it or we have tests on what was
said in the story and we're very much
oriented towards trying to get it right
trying to retrieve it and I sometimes
think we would be better advised to
accept that we're going to forget and
accept that the process of forgetting is
is building up this Reserve that our
ability to retrieve that information is
is going to improve but in the meantime
we also have to build up that reserve of
words that we will eventually be able to
access better and better Robert Bjork
also has as videos on interleaving
pointing out again how important it is
to to learn things in different
environments and at different times and
in different ways read about the same
subject matter in different books I've
called this grazing in the past not
worrying too much about what we retain
but making sure that we expose ourselves
to this information in different ways he
says for example
people are sometimes advised to always
learn something in the same place so if
you study study in your library or study
in your I don't know kitchen or whatever
and if you study it there and there is
research to show that if people you know
having studied something if they go back
to the place where they studied it
they'll remember it better however
you're better off to not do that to
study it here and then somewhere else
and somewhere else so your ability
ability to retrieve the information if
you go to a different setting may be
less however by studying that same
material in different environments even
you are building up your reserve of
information and that will eventually
give you more information even though in
the short run your ability to retrieve
the information is reduced a good
example of
learning things in different
environments learning and forgetting
building up our Reserve is the way I use
link on my iPad could be on your iPhone
or Android as well or on the web so if I
look at our many stories for example
lesson 59 I can read it in the full
lesson mode or I can go you know so here
for example here's page the next page
but I can also look at it one sentence
at a time so that's a different
experience varying the experience the
way we do things is a good thing to do
here for example I have a number of
words that I am trying to learn I don't
spend a lot of time deliberately trying
to remember these words but I can still
go through some of the you know
exercises here right after the page so I
might say well is accessible I hope uh
battalary
yeah
in
levantine okay A little bum
and I don't
try too hard to remember these things I
just kind of go through them the money
in other words being no being asking
so I get it wrong it doesn't matter if I
get it wrong continue and then in what
you will soon be seeing is the
opportunity then to to reassemble this
into a sentence I do it not for all the
text but I do it to some extent but the
key thing is I don't worry about what I
don't understand I don't worry about
what I forget I vary how I do things
sometimes I do it in full text mode
sometimes I do it you know sentence at a
time sometimes I do easy content such as
the mini stories sometimes I do more
difficult content I never worry about
what I forget because I know that
forgetting is the key to learning
so I just wanted to mention that because
a lot of people seem to get frustrated
when they forget things forgetting Is
Not a Bad Thing forgetting lubricator
forgetting is a good thing you want to
forget and relearn and hear it in
another context and read it in another
context trust the fact that eventually
the vocabulary will stick but expose
yourself to a variety of contexts and
don't just try to learn one sort of
limited group of vocabulary items in one
specific way but rather build up your
vocabulary Reserve because you're gonna
need it so increase your vocabulary by
forgetting
thank you for listening bye for now